so this video of Russian Foreign
Minister Sergei Lavrov on Wednesday
appearing to scold NBC's veteran
reporter Andrea Mitchell as Andrea
Mitchell was trying to ask Rex Tillerson
our Secretary of State trying to ask him
a series of questions
it appears that Lavrov says to her in
his best English he could he asked her
who raised you and where did you get
your manners let's take a look at the
video
who was close who was bringing you up
who was giving you your manners you know
alright so you can hear in the
background at the second half of the
video you can hear in the background
asking the question to Rex Tillerson she
said mr. secretary the Russians don't
believe the intelligence with regard to
Syria the chemical weapons and the
attack and the subsequent missile strike
and then she continues to say how
confident are you mr. secretary and
that's where Lavrov cut in and in his
English said who was bringing you up
basically who raised you and taught you
your manners to me that you know I have
a lot of feelings about this but what's
your take back well he either meant that
or who asked you to speak which either
way is incredibly condescending right
it's it's condescending on every single
level in my opinion you know I've had a
lot of people once I started discussing
this on Twitter I had people respond to
me and saying well Andrea Mitchell broke
decorum and because she broke decorum
that she was in the wrong here but
here's the thing with decorum and
journalism if you abide by all of the
rules set out by politicians to be
properly to be in the right decorum then
you're very rarely going to get an
opportunity to ask the important
questions case in point is the fact that
when Rex Tillerson met with
off-the-record meeting with Vladimir
Putin he didn't even take the press pool
so sometimes you have to break decorum
to give the appropriate amount of
accountability right this state
department is the least transparent in
recent history I think that's pretty
clear they stopped doing the daily press
briefings for about six weeks for
Trump's first six weeks in office they
weren't even holding those briefings and
Andrea Mitchell covers the State
Department she'll ask Rex Tillerson
questions all the time and she'll just
he'll just flat out ignore her right and
we see we've seen this I guess about a
month maybe a month and a half ago where
she was here in the United States asking
risk Tillerson questions and then she
was escorted out by one of Tilson's
aides so the thing to me that jumps out
about this is that of all people in all
frameworks
Russia should not be lecturing any
journalists about anything you know it
may have been too much and let's start
here I'm not personally a fan of this
type of tactic right it's just me I just
kind of personally I'm skittish I don't
really like to see this this kind of
gotcha you know guerilla style tactic I
don't trick question though it's not a
coterie question it's not a gotcha
question but it is a I'm going to jump
in at the most inopportune time and ask
you a question kind of those you know
the the roving journalists who just pop
up on people and ask some questions I'm
not really a fan of it however sometimes
journalists have to do it so it's not a
matter of whether we like this tactic or
not it's a matter of do they have the
right to do this and if even if it's a
breach of decorum absolutely sometimes
journalists have to do this and what I
think is that in Russia you don't really
have as many privileges and rights as a
journalist and that's saying it very
lightly I mean these reports of almost
200 journalists who may have been killed
covering important news in Russia so you
know it just seems to stand out to me is
even more grossly repugnant because of
who it's coming from and the statement
that it makes with regard to the freedom
of the press and if the State Department
was actually holding joint press
conferences and doing the daily
briefings exact would be no need for
Andrea Mitchell eggs but in in that
conversation and maybe you know we
wouldn't be on the side of this Russian
official based on what he said but we
would say I know maybe should say the
question for later right exactly and
because there are no opportunities for
her to ask these questions of Rex
Tillerson she is going to ask first of
all she's she she does this she's she's
bull she's a bulldog journalist she
would get out there and ask questions
until you either completely ignore her
and that's that's how you have to be
that way in as an actual journalist so
it's no you know for me to say I'm not
really a fan of this tactic it's not a
reflection on her it's just a reflection
on me I just don't really like the
tactic but you have to use it when when
when you're being shut out by
politicians and and what I see the most
happening in in this exchange what
stands out to me is that Russia
is not accustomed to journalists acting
out of order right this is this is
really a statement to me that Russia you
know this is this doesn't fly in Russia
and you're in a different country so you
better abide by the run no not so much
because you know here we are we have the
freedom of the press here we do have
some infringement on that we have some
cases I'm sure somebody can throw some
anecdotal examples of journalists
disappearing here in the United States
but comparatively speaking there is no
comparison and you have to wonder if
this Russian official would make the
same questions to a male reporter -
right it's possible though in Russia and
with the Russian journalists it's
possible because and and this is I guess
I could sum it up here in Russia
journalists fear the politicians right
and you know ideally in America the
ideal framework is for politicians to
fear journalists there are plenty of
examples of that not being the case but
but that should be the case journalists
politicians should fear journalists
journalists should not fear politicians
and this is an example here in Russia
that is disgusting on so many levels
whether or not you like that political
that journalistic tactic is irrelevant
what matters is does she have the right
to do it and so long as the Secretary of
State is avoiding questions yes she
should do it and do it as often as she
can